so what it's illegal to be in Canada and
say something about trans people or what
I don't know and you know anymore it's
like dude you know what's violence
violence here's the thing that our
violence is stabbing someone choking
someone shooting someone smacking
someone you know
hey saying doing this hey [__] you
that's not violence okay now granted
there's a sliding scale all right if
you're out there trying to incite a mob
yeah I don't think that that should be
legal hey come on let's get them that's
that's violence hey look at those people
who aren't dressing the way they should
look at the people whose color aren't a
shade to my liking get them that's
violence that's the kind of non-silence
that's violence but the second you just
are silent that's not violence silence
is violence no
not silence isn't violence either that's
how much you know silences in violence
silence and not they don't want you to
be talking and they don't want you to
not be talking
no matter what you're doing violence
right that's basically what they're
saying in Canada because it passes rule
to where if you're around like a hundred
meters at a Tran if there's like more
than three trans people together and you
say something
against trans people you go to J you get
you go to jail or get fined or something
and I'm just like okay
so look you talk about free speech and
all this [__] fine you know free speech
and people are like
you know they're taking free speech from
us dude it's gone already it's it's gone
they don't have free speech in Canada
now I am on tour in Canada coming up in
September October whatever the [__] I'm
gonna go out there and I'm gonna [__]
let them have it the way I do all right
I don't dude I want I would never know I
would never
right I'm sure it under the Arts it's
okay and it's not like we're doing a big
trans rally and by the way I love when
bad Love Trains more than regular people
I love them more than regular people
um
it's it but it is
hilarious how at the [__] thing they
were like uh a bunch of uh they were
like having a political rally and they
were like because we think it's violence
if they say that and they're like behind
them it's like it's it why the the the
people that they pick uh the of the
trans people to represent the thing it's
always they're always it's always they
look like The Fifth Element you know
it's like ah or or uh uh Rainbow Bright
and it's okay even if a a chick that
identifies as a chick that dresses like
this you you'd be like whoa but if you
say whoa because you know they'd be like
that's violence you're like all right
you know how about this too much makeup
is a lot right you know and uh I don't
care if you're a guy or a girl or
identify as a guy or a girl
but I'm the bully right because I'm
saying this and I know the other thing
is I know that most people agree with
what I'm saying but okay they're gonna
limit my ads because I said this or
whatever it is but the whole point is
they it's not taking the Free Speech
away they took it and
I you know I understand too like you
can't say certain things on YouTube you
can't say certain things on Instagram
saying certain things
that's definitely a slippery slope
because if they you know they are
companies and they can do what they want
the second you start caving to things I
do think though that some things like I
don't think you should be able to say
whatever the [__] you want on certain
platforms because it's definitely leads
to
deaths
but you know
I don't know
I guess there needs to be a better
system figuring out what the violent
things to be said are right everyone's
so mixed up man I feel like the trans
people who are truly trans that are like
I'm a woman
but were born biologically a male or I
don't know how to say without getting in
trouble but that they are even like oh
God can we just
can you stop guys I just want to be a
woman and I am a woman and just chill
right
or maybe I'm wrong
um who knows what I do know is there's
no free speech in Canada
[Music]